[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
happy sunday with all due respect to
devonta
adams this club is more fun than the
madden 99.
welcome to the squad ride presented by
draftkings live in the bluetooth report
app
my name is cabby richards in the middle
is our betting expert kelly stewart and
the general
of the winners only our army that is
greg ivory
we've been on anytime touchdowns on the
show and thank you to nick chubb
who scored for us on his birthday last
week we improved the 12 and four so
salute to you
only thing is man what a terrible
birthday present to get handed an
l by the new york jets sorry about that
my g
uh kelly listen there are a handful of
ten win teams trying to get into the afc
playoffs miami cleveland miami cleveland
tennessee indianapolis and baltimore
what betting advice so what words of
caution do you have to our audience
when betting on must-win teams to win in
the final week of the regular season
specifically regarding must-win teams
gabby it's baked into the cake the
bookmakers
know that people know who has to win
to get in but that doesn't necessarily
mean
that they're going to cover the spread
so keep in mind there are like you said
a handful of teams here
either that need to win to get in that
need to win to get home field advantage
need to win to secure a first-round buy
that being said it doesn't mean they're
going to cover the number some of these
numbers are rather large this week so
i'm looking at some really
ugly underdogs that have a chance to
play spoilers and you love underdogs
like you love me and gray yay listen we
uh we've been on
touchdowns on this show and uh sorry we
we know that there are teams that have
nothing to play for
and we know there are players ready to
score touchdowns for
us this is the list that we put together
based on your favorite picks
to score a touchdown in week 17. shout
out to the newest member of the 99 club
devonta adams who scorched
tennessee last week with three
touchdowns on a sunday night this is a
great list and here are some great
pitches
that you guys sent us
our number one pick for the week
wait hold on i see something over there
devonte adams anytime touchdown score
dk metcalf want a
[Music]
we're gonna let the catnip choose who
it's gonna be
that's it kyler murray
lamar derek henry devonte adams
block of the day boys nick chubb scoring
at least one touchdown today
yes sir lock it in
yes uncles horns uh let's continue the
arrival of 2021 with
one of the few positive things to emerge
from 2020
greg ivory doing greg ivory things
cabbie yes sir hey cabby it's a busy
morning man i'm all over the place the
comments got me
rolling okay uh of that as you can see
it's a new year but it's the same handy
dandy ipad i'm in the comments right now
kathy in the comments they're they're
literally all over the place i got
jay jace t60 saying he likes taylor
and miles gaskins to score a touchdown
today
uh i got j man 3-2-1
he wants devonta to score a touchdown
today
guess what both of those guys are
walking away with hoodies
i'm feeling real generous cabbie i want
to keep going but i know you're just
going to cut me up
so with that being said back to you
brother this is the
this is the only time we're going to ask
you to pump the brakes because we have a
full show ahead and we
i know you want to give away a bunch of
hoodies listen we have five legendary
videos to show you
and one of them will be our final squad
ride of the season so let's begin our
first pitch
comes from louis de castro the new
year's legend
what you got first lock of 2021
stefan diggs anytime touchdown score
winners only please you heard it here
first
oh i like that they added the please
well done teamwork makes the dream work
uh you're next to po your opponent uh
comes from
the treat legend will ross107
what's up vr betting let's figure out
anytime touchdown score this week
let's go let's go
keep going it's a treat
the treats look
pick a player you can pick any player
there we go ronald jones lock it in
that dog looks like it's on punishment
for losing too many parlays over the
season so we have
stefan diggs versus ronald jones ii
g-money what'd you think of the videos
and the match-up
uh new year's legend i mean what what a
better way to ring in the new year
uh than saying winners only please
shouts out to
shouts out to his wife there i mean she
came through and she said to please well
let's talk about the pick gabby
stefan diggs i mean he has four
touchdowns in his last three games on
fire
he's been balling he's been balling
three straight games 100
100 uh plus 100 plus receiving yards
so i mean the guy's been bawling uh he's
sitting at plus 145 i love the plus
money
do think the uh the browns will have to
to show up today against that pittsburgh
steelers uh
defense i think i think the starters are
playing still but anyway
anyway stefan dicks loving the plus 145
now let's talk about the other pick now
this show i don't know why but we have
the most disobedient dogs
dogs just do not listen i'm not
i don't know why but with that being
said
uh the ronald jones pick at -106
uh i don't know he he missed the he
missed two games with the broken finger
uh he's been on the covet list i don't
know if i want to
lay that with ronald jones maybe though
but kelly talked to me
stefan diggs ronald jones what are you
thinking look i've tried to do this with
my dog so many times and it just doesn't
matter cause they don't even let me get
the treats on the floor
and stay this dog is great he just looks
a little nervous so
anyway i'm not nervous against this i
already know i'm taking stuff
diggs i do like you said greg through
the last four games he scored a
touchdown
point blank period the end no disrespect
to mr jones but his name is not aaron
jones and that concerns me here
remember a couple weeks ago my best bet
was the falcons they were up
nothing over tampa bay and what did tom
brady have to do
he had to air that ball out they had to
abandon the run he had to start throwing
downfield
that is what they're going to have to do
again today so if i'm picking between
these two stephon diggs
is an easy choice excellent work
stefan diggs kelly you're rocking with
stefan diggs i'm into the comments and
they're rocking with stefan too
uh but they i also see some uh
some jones in here but i got zelka
saying diggs
touchdown for sure shouts out to you
you're walking away with a hoodie
uh shouts out to a the goat a the goat
got
jones in here seven points he says jones
scores seven points i mean they're back
and forth next one cabbie
i'm just going to make a decision all
right is able to make a decision
let's go all right here we go here we go
locked in all right here we go i got
maxo
rexel landed on max rexel
lock in jones so guess what cabbie kelly
that means we are riding with the treat
legend
and ronald jones moving on round oh nice
little surprise
little twist ending there okay that's
the end of round one ronald
jones and the treat legend moving on to
round two
let's get it our next pitch comes from
eminem im
is that really you marshall mathers new
year
new lock
back middle
miles gasket anytime touchdown score
lock it in
have some good range from the do only
play in uh
cornell and it wasn't marshall mathers
but uh probably has a backyard
similar size to detroit's finest okay so
miles gaskin is the next
player uh uh pitch for the dolphins
g-money what'd you think of the video
and what do you think of miles miles
gaskins
chances today to score a touchdown
uh i'm just glad no one's calling me a
cornhole legend but with that being said
the guy did throw i i i appreciate the
toss
let's talk about the pick though kelly
and cabby let's talk about the pick
my guy mouse gaskin showed up last week
too bad i wasn't in the fantasy uh
in the fantasy championship because i
did have him on my fantasy team
but he showed up last week two
touchdowns against the raiders
dolphins is in the win and they're in
game
i think that he shows up today that
offense has to get rolling they have two
at quarterback cabbie
and uh they like to dunk the ball the
miles gaskins a lot out of the backfield
so i can see him uh having potentially a
chance to score in this game
and sitting at plus 115 i'm loving it
i'm actually i'm absolutely loving it
now kelly you talk to me
uh we got mal's gaskins we got
uh ronald jones what are you thinking
and in the comments you guys tell me
what you're thinking in the comments i
need i i need to uh
i need to see which way we gotta rock
here
you know what greg this is easy for me
uh let's see was it week three
week four i gave out the bills as a best
bet i believe
and i said no problem they're gonna beat
the rams so badly and they looked
so good until they couldn't stop the run
and to this week they still cannot stop
the run
so what's gonna happen here miles
gaskins as you mentioned little dink and
dunk pass
from touhou maybe a little handoff in
the backfield doesn't matter
miles gaskins is scoring a td here i did
play the dolphins when they were two and
a half in a
teaser above three and seven make sure
you guys do that
when you're playing teasers you want to
go through those key numbers uh but at
three
the dolphins kind of make me a little
nervous here i'm not sure why the line
didn't move in the other direction
but i do think gaskins will score td for
us today
wow i mean i'm looking at the comments
and it's literally a landslide like i
don't see any ronald jones junior
i don't i don't i don't see anything any
not
one cabbie literally not one all i see
is gasses gasses got some gaskets but
let me start giving away some hoodies
for these gaskins uh
before these gaskets pick deckman says
gaskins i'm giving you a hoodie
uh it's going so fast i gotta be quick
here we go d grin 57 gaskins
gonna win me my fantasy ship uh shouts
out to you
you're walking away with a hoodie uh i
like this one ellis sauce 23 says
gaskins break dip dip td gaskins y'all
probably might not know what that's that
bay area talk right there
and it was you getting the hoodie for
that brody
uh here we go kevin i got one more jam
ram said gaskins goes off for 150
plus and the td with like seven fire
emojis wow so uh
that was a fire take yeah yeah that was
a fire take
you think he's gonna have a big game uh
shouts out to you jram you're walking
away with a hoodie nice work jram i
think cabbie you've got a lot it's a
it's a yeah yeah it's apparent like i'm
sorry
it's but i thought it was apparent we're
walking we're miles gaskins is moving on
mal's gasses in the cornhole legend is
moving on i like i like that last
commenter who has
who thinks he might repeat what he did
to uh oakland last week which um
had kelly kelly was a fire emoji
watching um
john gruden coach that game so miles
gaskin
and the cornhole legend move on to round
three
much appreciated thank you for the
commenters the tournament continues so
let's get it
our next uh it's a new year
the same saint nick so d lutz what gift
did you bring for us did you find under
your tree you sent a legend you
that's weird it looks like i missed a
christmas gift
to be our betting followers from the
betting gods
sick
it's labeled free money
week 17 deandre hopkins anytime
touchdown scorer
well boys the gods have spoken
yo i like that dude's look by the way my
guy looks like a tight end so we have
de'andre hopkins and miles
casket the match-up in uh in round three
uh g-money what'd you think of the pick
and uh what'd you think of uh
the santa legend
cabbie gotta love the bonus present
under the tree
uh but it's time it's time to uh put
that tree into the uh garage because
it's becoming a fire hazard now
but shout out shouts out to the pick man
shouts out to the pick that was a
present underneath the tree deandre
hopkins
sitting at plus money i'm absolutely
loving that he has two touchdowns in his
last four games
it's a big game for that cardinals team
where uh
the stars are gonna have to show up in
this one they're gonna have to show up
in this one
so i can see deandre hopkins getting
into the end zone
but i need you guys in the comments i
need gifts
i need gifts only gifts in the comments
tell me
if it's miles gaskins or if it's deandre
hopkins
uh but before that kelly you talk to me
talk to me first which way are you
leaning
i don't even want to tell you about this
pick this is wild
i bet the rams plus three all jokes
aside my buddy puts out this tweet
about fading one of his friends i was
like oh my lord i have to take the rams
this is terrible
they got a backup quarterback from wake
forest i had to google the kid
i was like this is nuts just before we
came on
i saw our fearless social media leader
sam richmond tweet
that the rams were down to a pick em
that is some major steam so be
very very cautious there could be some
sort of injury or something going on
here
uh with this cardinals team which makes
me concerned about hopkins
greg you had mentioned during rehearsals
that kylo murray wasn't 100
that could be it again guys do your
research because this one is
very interesting in terms of a line move
if they don't have their starting qb or
he's not 100
how is he going to throw to his best
weapon hopkins at plus 100 looks trappy
already to me
as i mentioned the bills can't stop the
run i feel like gaskins is the easy pick
here
kelly it looks like there's a fake
kelly going on in the comments better
that way
listen it's so much better when you guys
fade me
they faded me with ohio state i said
sprinkle a little bit on that money line
i mean this is so much better when i get
faded it gives me this like
superhero power greg so more fade kelly
hashtags in the comments give out
everybody that's doing it hashtag fade
kelly in the comments great give them a
hoodie
go i got jrjrj93 he gave me a deandre
hopkins gift
i see they're fading you with the gifts
kelly they're failing you with the gifts
i see a bunch
of money easy money 98 he got another
deandre hopkins gift going on
he was it was actually him burning uh uh
the guy from the redskins back in the
day anyway we're moving on moving on we
got deckman26
nah not josh norman um
uh deckman26 he gave me a fire deandre
hopkins gift
uh it's pretty apparent next one i just
want to give out another hoodie
jaden rb jayden rb you're walking away
with it he gave me out
he gave out another fire gift uh cabbie
it's very apparent
uh deandre hopkins the andre hopkins in
the santa legend
is moving on to the next round oh wow
all right i mean i
i immediately think of the deandre hop
do you guys the
the game winner against buffalo double
coverage my guy goes up yeah
with the fan jordan gloves yeah that's
that's the moment that i think of when i
think of uh deandre hopkins and maybe it
does for the audience as well so
d-hop is moving on to the final round
whoever wins this matchup
is our squad ride in week 17 so let's
meet the final legend
we have our final pitch uh
is a legend indeed and certainly in
their neighborhood
the baby legend and nick frodo who you
got
yes
no words necessary devonte adams is the
pick and
uh the cutest baby we've seen in 2020
g-money what do you think of the devonta
adams pick and uh the carson
wentz jersey cabbie
forget about the abcs this baby knows
it's wops and that is winners
only please shout out to the baby legend
for picking this pick man
we're rocking with devonta adams here
devonta adams
uh the packers i mean
the packers they're facing uh chicago
devonte adams has to show up he just
he's just was elevated to 99 on
madden cabbie yeah i mean he's not too
many people that's a 99 all madden
devonte adams just joined the club on
wednesday he leads the nfl in receiving
touchdowns he has 17
why not let's get 18. why not why not
gabby let's get 18.
i mean laying the two dollars though
that's kind of throwing me off but um
winners only please and the baby picked
it shouts out to the baby legend
kelly you talk to me we got devonta
adams
we got deandre hopkins
two dollars plus money talk to me
you're right two dollars with the
devonta adams is about the right price
but when draftkings gives us that odd
boost at three to one i can't help but
turn it down
let me tell you this was a really cute
video i appreciate it i know i
understand
he's in the eagles jersey now i guess i
gotta make an eagles bet for later on
but that's beside the point
i just gave out the bears on twitter and
i made a lot of packers fans very angry
in the comments section i hate to break
it to you guys i
really really really like the bears
especially with that reverse line
movement today
but that doesn't mean that devonte adams
won't score a touchdown draftkings give
me that odds boost
i like three to one with devonta adams
all right
that was a little that was a little
twist there you know gave out the bears
on twitter but then
going with davonte adams the odds booth
is obviously hugely appreciated
and it's big time so get in the comments
tell greg what you think
send gifts or vote for your favorite
vote for the pro bowl receiver you think
is going to score this week
deandre hopkins or devonta adams
let g-money know there's going to be a
lot of scoreboard watching in
in tight playoff races in the afc but
those aren't the only games that can
make you money so kelly stewart
please give people your best bet in week
17.
gabby we're talking about the afc and
i've got the toilet bowl for the afc
let me tell you what is going to happen
here
this is nuts it's story time from the
sportsbook there i am
last saturday night the raiders the
dolphins
john gruden just score the touchdown you
win the game i cash my money line i cash
my plus two and a half
you have a shot to get into the playoffs
guess what he kicks the field goal
ryan fitzpatrick face mask kicks a field
goal
they lose game lands one have you guys
ever heard of a team losing a game twice
that's what i think is going to happen
to the raiders here
i understand drew locke not that great
as a broncos fan i know this broncos
team
that's why i bet their season win total
under and will still cash that bet i'm
also going to catch my raiders season
win total under today when they lose
to the denver broncos denver broncos
best bet plus two and a half denver
broncos
money line oh i like it get out
draftkings lock in the broncos
at plus two and a half or money line as
kelly just said
denver might have a losing record but
they're eight and seven against the
spread so keep that in mind
greg your handy-dandy ipad has the
answer we are looking for
who is the squad ride in week 17.
cabbie the comments has been flowing in
the comments have
been flowing in and uh
i believe it's another landslide is it
it's another landslide
if i'm being honest i see a lot of
devante adams
i see a lot of devante adams gif and uh
i just see a lot of defense devonta
adams into in the comments
i got ben the goat adams is going to get
10 receptions two touchdowns 125 yards
shouts out to ben for this uh the
predictions
happen but he can have one touchdown
just one
uh i'm gonna give somebody else i'm
gonna give some more hoodies out cabbie
okay i got
handy dandy ipad i believe i gave them a
hoodie last week
i'll just read their comment hopkins
three touchdowns let's go greg you to go
winners only please shouts out to you
thank you brother
i got new york champions every box for
you greg
that's what they do they just they just
pander to you for hoodies
i love it
98 devonte adams is the best receiver in
the league this year especially when the
with the healthy aaron rodgers
unstoppable
to you new york fan you're walking away
with a hoodie uh cabbie
it's apparent i got one more hoodie in
me one more hoodie in me
mikey simon devonte 12 catches 126 yards
three tds uh mikey simon you're walking
away with a hoodie
but uh it is very apparent
the riding with christ the winner yes
and the person we are riding with is
devonte
adams where is the graphic where's the
graphic i have to show you something
show you guys something that we and us
only can do here
on the squad right you see that minus
200 let's change the graphic please
let's change the graphic please the plus
300
that is the odds boost yes that
draftking is providing us here on the
squad ride
only uh make sure you guys
tune in to the br instagram well we will
be
riding with devonta adams today
to score a touchdown send in your videos
get on the story
but remember
in the comments i'm giving away some
more hoodies put it in the comments
thank you baby legend thank you nick
frodo much appreciated for the pick that
devonte adams pick
make sure you you tap in with vr social
to get the link to the odds boost
offered by draftkings that is very
important
send us your videos that is very
important uh
and also tap into g money or greg ivory
on ig
to ride with them on the stories all day
thank you to the commenters thank you to
a salute to everybody who won hoodies
and thank you to our legends
who are we to catch whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa
whoa cabbie welcome you know i gotta
jump in before you get off actually
you know i gotta jump the music's gonna
be playing the show is over
i messages right now i got things to do
before
kitty too you're walking away with a
hoodie joel
hearn you're walking away with a hoodie
m
lilo 80 winners only please you're
walking away with a hoodie
uh here we go a ballinger winner's only
please you're walking away
144. greggy bringing back the lockheed's
in 2022. you're walking away with it
uh salute to our other legends eminem
and
eminem i am d lutz and obviously nick
frodo and the baby legend
alongside kelly stewart and greg aubry
my name is cabby richards
good luck with your wagers be safe and
we'll see you next week playoff edition
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you